public sénat s'associe à l'événement
organisé ce 1er juillet ici au sénat
égalité professionnelle la loi à
l'épreuve des faits avec le cercle de
réflexion marie-claire agir pour
l'égalité on va donc faire le constat
d'un combat qui est loin d'être gagnée
notamment et on commence avec ça sur le
plan salarial cécile six ans ils ont le
même poste et travaille autant d'heures
pourtant leurs revenus sont différents
en fonction de leur sexe dans la plupart
des entreprises en matière salariale les
femmes sont toujours à la traîne à
travail équivalent elle gagne 17 % de
moins que les hommes et ce chiffre
s'accentue si l'on prend en compte le
volume de travail les femmes font
beaucoup plus de temps partiel que les
hommes dans ce cas la rémunération
moyenne des femmes est inférieure de 28%
à celle des hommes en majorité des
femmes
[Musique]
parce qu'elles ont vraiment envie de
travailler à temps plein mais parce
qu'elles sont obligées à le faire en
alternance à penser que c'est à elle de
s'occuper des enfants de la famille et
elle considère comme un en vérité un
deuxième travail que la femme fille en
plus de façon gratuite alors
obligé à accepter de travailler
à temps partiel des vies personnelles
qui freine également leur évolution dans
l'entreprise elles sont moins nombreuses
que les hommes à avoir des postes à
responsabilité seuls 22 % d'entre elles
sont présentes dans les comités de
direction mais ces chiffres devraient
évoluer car désormais des quotas oblige
les entreprises de plus de 250 salariés
à avoir 40% de femmes dans les comités
de direction elle leur impose aussi de
mesurer tous les ans les écarts de
rémunération entre les hommes et les
femmes grâce à un index de l'égalité
professionnelle
les hommes et les femmes ils vont pas
occuper le même genre de métiers dans
l'entreprise quand on construit cet
index d'égalité si on si on compare les
administratifs entre où elle est
majoritairement des femmes et donc entre
n ya pas beaucoup d'inégalités si on
compare les opérationnels entre plutôt
des hommes il ya pas beaucoup
d'inégalités entre et donc si vous
voulez ça va masquer les inégalités qui
en fait existe dans la structure globale
de l'entreprise plus de femmes en
politique pour représenter cette cause
pourrait encore faire évoluer la
législation
en attendant les nominations d'une femme
première ministre et d'une autre
présidente de l'assemblée nationale
peuvent déjà changer les regards sur les
femmes en responsabilité
on sait par parler des salaires dans ce
débat avec mes invités valérie
hoffenberg au bon soir bienvenus
cofondatrice du sac de réflexion
marie-claire agir pour l'égalité à
l'origine donc de cette journée de cet
événement ce 1er juillet au sénat et
présidente de connecting leader ce club
hinse a fait lahssini bonsoir bienvenue
vous êtes juriste experte en égalité
salariale créatrice de ma juste valeur
c'est une entreprise de formation de
coaching renégociation de rémunération
moi j'aurai besoin de vous je pense pour
de négocier les salaires aussi bref vous
avez vous trouvé on est on est pas là
pour parler de moi à marier loi bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes fondatrice de bouche
la boîte est membre de croissanceplus
j'accueille également bruno belin avec
nous en duplex bonsoir vous êtes
sénateur de la vienne et vous avez fait
tilt l'un des rapports des travaux menés
au sénat sur les inégalités en milieu
rural et du siècle pie des tarifs
politique est resté à mes côtés moi je
reste quand même estomaqué par ce
chiffre varie au fender avec 28 % 28 et
demi selon les dernières données de
l'insee j'avais l'impression qu'on
réussissait à réduire cet écart ou alors
est-ce que oui ou non il se réduit mais
comment il peut être aussi large coiffes
et bien écoutez vous avez les deux
sentiments qu'il faut avoir cirque le
premier c'est fou est estomaqué il faut
être révolté et il faut continuer à se
dire que c'est inacceptable et qui ont
donc il faut se battre pour enfin vous
me dites aussi que vous pensiez que tout
allait bien et je crois que c'est le
symbio s'améliorer alors ça s'améliore
mais ça n'empêche qu'il faut pas baisser
les bras parce que justement le danger
ça serait la fatigue de parler de cette
égalité femmes hommes et moi je vais
vous dire que j'entends dans les
entreprises est haute oui ça y est ça
fait des années qu'on en parle on a fait
des progrès oui et des progrès mais ce
chiffre reste inacceptable et donc il
faut continuer à agir il ya des mesures
structurelles sur lesquels il faut agir
il ya des mesures sociétal pour changer
l'image des femmes pour changer d'image
des hommes pour changer l'image du
pouvoir et sur lesquels nous devons tous
agir ça commence dès l'enfance ça
commence absolument vous avez raison
c'est dès l'enfance dès la maternelle on
se rend compte déjà dans la maternelle
dans les travaux que nous avons fait
avec le think tank que la manière dont
sont conçus les cours de récréation où
les garçons occupent l'espace du milieu
en jouant au foot et que les filles sont
sur le côté pour ne pas être touché par
le ballon est bien original créé sur
foot quand même
suffisamment dans les cours les cours de
récréation ça se joue aussi dans
l'orientation ça se joue aussi à
l'université quand on voit les scandales
qu'il ya eu récemment avec tous ces
viols il faut le dire dans nos grandes
écoles comment voulez vous que les
parents aient envie d'envoyer leurs
filles dans des écoles comme celle ci
comment voulez vous que les filles
s'épanouissent quand dans des écoles
dans des grandes écoles françaises qui
font la fierté de notre système on
entend encore des situations pareilles
donc la loi est essentielle puisque on
est là aussi pour pas mais aussi la
société dans son ensemble ne doit pas se
fatiguer et doit continuer à lutter
c'est très important ce que vous dites
parce qu'effectivement on peut avoir
quand on quand on donne look on a le
sentiment qu'on rabâche un peu les mêmes
choses au bout d'un mois on peut baisser
les bras c'est cet écart salarial il
s'appelle à s'immiscer vraiment votre
job de le réduire est ce que vous direz
que c'est le dernier ou l'un des
derniers tabous dans un pays parce que
pendant déjà on a du mal à parler
d'argent en général est ce que c'est
encore plus compliqué quand on est une
femme moi j'ai l'habitude de dire que
le tabou de l'argent est le dernier
bastion du patriarcat en réalité
aujourd'hui on s'aperçoit que l'argent
est un véritable tabou c'est un tabou
qui est culturel dans notre société
française
le tabou de l'argent en france on parle
pas d'argent en france de la même
manière dont on aborde le sujet aux
etats-unis par exemple ou dans d'autres
pays et effectivement il faut apprendre
aux femmes à parler argent il faut leur
apprendre à négocier il faut leur
apprendre à investir leur argent et à
sang poiret de ce dernier bastion du
patriarcat car à mon sens la liberté
politique des femmes débutent avec leur
liberté économique et on va très bien je
pense que si aux états unis les femmes
avaient un vrai pouvoir économique on
n'aurait pas vécu le drame qu'on a vécu
il ya quelques il ya quelques jours avec
cette décision de la cour suprême la
liberté tout court quand on voit
l'évolution pardon à la famille du
couple et cetera la femme s'est libérée
du patriarcat parce qu'elles étaient
autonomes financièrement ap ce qu'elle a
pu
demander le divorce et qu'elle peut être
autonome aussi en étant seul enfin ça
c'est vrai que c'est c'est quand même le
point de départ d'une liberté et
d'ailleurs même quand on parle de la
lutte contre les violences faites aux
femmes ça passe aussi par l'autonomie
financière parce qu'on oublie que la
plupart des femmes qui restent et bien
c'est parce qu'elles n'ont pas cette
autonomie financière marié il faut
peut-être rappeler aussi quelque chose
d'important c'est que la mixité est
finalement le plus on se rapproche d'une
mixité d'une égalité salariale un
produit plus l'entreprise est efficace
soit c'est de la rentabilité dont on
parle aussi oui c'est exactement ça je
sais plus comment faire pour que
l'égalité soit là parce que l'on
accompagne énormément de groupes et
d'administration pour que les femmes
montent dans dans les strates vers le
comex est en fait quand on voit les
inégalités salariales finalement cela
représente aussi la place des femmes
dans les postes à responsabilités mais
quel qu'il soit dans l'entreprise à la
tête des entreprises aussi et on se rend
compte que dans tous les domaines
vraiment tous les domaines on dépasse
jamais 20 22% là et c'était écrit 22%
mais plus on descend dans dans les
strates d'entreprises moins il ya de
femmes par exemple pour les pme c'est on
descend à 16 % de femmes dans les comics
donc on se rend compte que dans tous les
postes de pouvoir et de responsabilité
on ne dépasse pas 20% de l'homme et
parfois il suffit juste d'un verset les
chiffres et de se dire mais si on
dépassait pas 20 % d'hommes dans les
postes à responsabilité il serait
comment notre monde donc ça fait
toujours du bien de remettre les choses
à leur place et ça c'est valable dans
l'entrepreneuriat dans le salariat on
voit bien que ça ne bouge pas et
effectivement pour répondre à votre
question on a deux cent quarante pour
cent de croissance pour les entreprises
du cac 40 les plus féminisées 240 % de
croissance qui peut se passer de 240 %
de croissance mais quand enfin les chefs
d'entreprise sont des gens intelligents
et qui veulent que les entreprises
soient les plus rentable possible
diamant donc oui g7 cette phrase là et
vous venez de donner cet argument de
l'hypercroissance des groupes qui sont
les plus mixtes et pourtant ben ils s'y
mettent pas tous jeu comprends pas alors
moi non plus je comprends pas et
franchement j'ai appris ça par tous les
bouts effectivement comme tu disais
comme vous disiez toutes les deux c'est
vraiment un héritage culturel historique
etc mais rien ne justifie ce parce que
toutes les études le disent plus une
mixité puis intéressant dans ce que vous
être candidate on va on va peut-être
je n'affirme rien de curières je pose la
question si on voulait il ya des raisons
structurelles c'est un peu quand on dit
c'est 25% c'est tout au long de la
carrière après vous avez un autre
chiffre keane cents à niveau de
qualification et de responsabilité il ya
je dirais que celui ci il est encore
plus choquant si l'on peut dire sur
parce que pourquoi ces 27 % c'est que
parce que vous avez beaucoup plus de
femmes comme l'a dit marc et tout à
l'heure qui sont dans des postes avec
des catégories plus faible et vous avez
moins de femmes qui sont dans les postes
les plus avec les rémunérations les plus
élevées d'ailleurs on sait que dans la
loi dans l'index pénicaud l'un des
critères qui est le moins bien respectés
par les entreprises c'est celui ci c'est
à dire que d'avoir la parité autant de
femmes que d'hommes dans les dix plus
hauts salaires et là je crois qu'il ya
que 2 % des entreprises qui l'ont donc
on voit à ce point là maintenant c'est
aussi qu'il faut c'est à tous les
niveaux qu'il faut faire bouger des
choses c'est à dire qu'il faut permettre
aux femmes d'avoir de la prod et
promotion et de grandir au sein
d'entreprises et donc c'est à tous les
secteurs et à tous les étages de
l'entreprise qu'il faut former parce que
vous avez aussi des cadres qui se disent
mais pourquoi elle et pourquoi pas moi
qui reste encore avec des stéréotypes
sur le rôle des femmes il ya trois
moments qui sont importants le premier
c'est le recrutement est malheureusement
s'aperçoit déjà que une femme qui sort
d'une jeune fille qui sort de politique
ni qu'un jeune qui sort de polytechnique
et bien c'est invraisemblable mais quand
ils arrivent au premier emploi il y a
déjà des différences de salaires
peut-être parce que justement les jeunes
filles ne savent pas ne savent pas
négocier leur salaire l'exemple en
profite aussi et que les entreprises
absolument vous avez totalement raison
deuxièmement c'est celui de du congé de
maternité
et de maternité donc là c'est aussi le
deuxième
la deuxième étape où en général la
différence de salaire s'accentue donc
c'est vrai que tout ce qui est les lois
sur la parentalité et cetera vont aider
en tout cas on le souhaite et puis après
vous avez le troisième écart qui est ce
fameux plafond de verre où on considère
que la femme c'est bien elle travaille
bien mais non mais le poste à
responsabilités enfin quand on voit le
nombre de d'entreprises du cac 40 qui
sont dirigées par une femme vous savez
comme il y en a le new dawn voilà voilà
donc il c'est catherine mcgregor donc il
n'en reste qu'une et donc on peut
s'apprendre je voudrais entendre bruno
belin tout de suite pour pourrait
peut-être faire le constat on parlait de
postes stéréotypé
c'est encore pire en milieu rural c'est
à dire qu'on voit que les femmes sont
souvent
freinées bloquée dans ses posts
stéréotypé avec donc là aussi des
conséquences des conséquences en matière
de salaire
alors déjà aujourd'hui sur le débat
s'est effectivement il faudra racheter
rabâcher et rabat chez et
en ce qui concerne la carrière
professionnelle bien évidemment je crois
que tout va commencer au niveau de
l'école à sion l'explication l'éducation
tout commençait là et c'est là où il ya
un gros effort à faire même si
effectivement on a conscience d'un salon
de difficultés concernant le cette
difficulté qui est accentuée en milieu
rural le maître mot est l'absence ou la
difficulté de mobilité et on voit bien
que bien souvent la femme dans un schéma
lequel caricatural mais va ses fastes et
par rapport à son coût par rapport à ces
familles on a même entretenu dans des
auditions ont été faits dans cette
mission que le président annick billon
on a quand même en donne une fois le mot
de sacrifices je démens de santé sur des
questions de difficultés de mobilité par
rapport à un véhicule unique dans le
foyer est donc cette question de
mobilité créer un frein à la carrière
professionnelle et à l'évolution de
cette carrière professionnelle mais
évidemment même élu par rapport à la
ruralité tout doit commencer aujourd'hui
par une pédagogie une explication la
formation et dès l'école oui on voyait
ce chiffre il ya 80% des femmes qui ont
le permis de conduire en milieu rural
pour 90% des sommes donc effectivement
cette question de la mobilité elle est
centrale vous avez commencé à l'évoquer
mais c'est vraiment intéressant et on va
faire maintenant avec jonathan du ps de
se pencher sur les lois qui ont été
votées
ces dernières années re bonsoir
jonathan alors quand même un certain
nombre de progrès ou de bon en avant ces
dernières années oui la dernière en date
elle date de 2018 c'est la loi sur la
liberté de choisir son avenir
professionnel est en fait elle a mis en
place un outil d'évaluation pour
permettre de mesurer voire de corriger
des différences de rémunérations dans
les entreprises entre les femmes et les
hommes est donc cette loi en a créé une
sorte de barèmes si on peut dire avec un
principe assez simple un shack
entreprises d'au moins 50 salariés et
bien le calcul est elle publie sur
internet son index d'égalité femmes
hommes une note en fait 200 points qui
dépend de plusieurs critères suivants la
taille de l'entreprise quelles sont ces
critères et bien vous allez les voir
tout de suite s'afficher sur votre écran
il ya notamment la suppression des
écarts de rémunération la chance d'avoir
une augmentation ou d'avoir une
promotion figurent aussi dans le barème
la garantie d'être augmentée en retour
d'un congé maternité par exemple ou
encore la parité dans les dix plus hauts
postes de l'entreprise le texte en plus
à une valeur contraignante a ainsi dans
les trois ans les entreprises ne
parviennent pas à obtenir une note d'au
moins 75 sur 100 et bien en fait elles
s'exposent à des pénalités d'ordre
financière et elles doivent aussi après
se remettre un peu à la page et corrigé
effectivement il est pour que ces écarts
on vient de l'expliquer salariaux
diminue encore faut-il que les femmes
puissent accéder à des postes de
responsabilités similaires à celui des
hommes et là encore il y avait une loi
qui avait porté cette ambition de casser
ces plafonds de verre la loi copé
zimmermann qui vient d'ailleurs de fêter
ses 10 ans ce texte avait pour ambition
d'instaurer la parité dans les conseils
d'administration des grandes entreprises
cotées en bourse de plus de 500 salariés
dont grosso modo c'est un plaisir
entreprises du cac 40 la commission aux
droits des femmes du sénat elle avait
récemment dressé un bilan de cette loi
et vous allez le voir s'afficher aussi
en dix ans les sénatrices relève que le
chemin parcouru est immense la france se
situe aujourd'hui au premier rang
mondial en termes de féminisation des
conseils d'administration de ces grandes
entreprises avec plus de 46% de femmes
en 2021 dans les hautes sphères de ces
sociétés du cac 40 donc ça c'est le bon
côté des choses mais le sénat a relevé
qu' il n'y a pas eu de ruissellement
escomptés dans les entreprises plus
petites non et c'est là que le blaise
thomas les conseils d'administration des
plus petites entreprises pourtant cotée
en bourse est bien le compte que moins
d'un tiers de femmes pire encore dans
les comités de direction des entreprises
non cotées de plus de 250 salariés et
bien là on compte seulement 25% de
femmes et sans parler des pme qui
n'entre même pas dans le champ de la loi
copé zimmermann
donc on voit bien ya encore beaucoup à
faire merci jonathan pour tous ces
détails marié loi sur le lundi cela noté
susurre sens et c'est quand même alors
c'est un outil qui est utilisé comment
il est utilisé j'imagine par des
salariés on sait que les les jeunes
diplômés d'universités ou de grandes
écoles regardent de plus en plus le
bilan est ré ce responsabilité sociale
sociétale des entreprises mais aussi les
questions de mixité de parité donc ce ce
score il doit être regardée par les
futurs diplômés clairement les jeunes et
les femmes ont les mêmes aspirations il
ya ce besoin de sens qui est très fort
et qui compte 1 dans l'attraction des
talents l'attractivité des talents la
rétention des talents ça c'est très
important
donc effectivement c'est un index qui
comptent qui a permis aussi de changer
les mentalités il n'est pas parfait
parce qu'il ya des moyens d'avoir un
score qui est bon même s'il ya des
dysfonctionnements en interne lors il
n'est pas parfait mais il a le mérite
d'exister et donc de permettre ce
changement de mentalité et en interne
pas de compter comme disait tout à
l'heure valérie de compter les affronter
les différences de compter tout ce qu'il
faut améliorer dans le vide là ce mérite
là d'accord il a fait la ceni de les
femmes que vous conseiller que vous
coacher j'ai une double question 1
est-ce qu'elle regarde ces indices ou
est ce que finalement elle s'est déjà
dans une entreprise avec une situation
qui est insupportable et qu'elle
qu'elles veulent corriger moi je pense
que les femmes commencent à regarder ces
indices oui mais effectivement quand
elle recherche quand elles sont en
recherche d'emploi c'est pas la chaussée
s'était pas l'élément prioritaire qui va
aiguiller leur recherche d'emploi en
général quand on est dans une démarche
et une posture de chercheurs d'emploi ou
chercheuse d'emploi on a plutôt envie
d'avoir un job qui fait du sens pour
nous qui correspond à vos compétences et
qui soit également qui nous offre un
environnement de travail qui soit
cohérent avec notre situation familiale
un envoi ce que j'observe dans
l'exercice de ma pratique c'est que les
femmes n'ont aucune idée de leur valeur
sur le marché de l'emploi elles n'ont
aucune idée du prix de leur compétence
de leur qualification de leur expertise
et leur expérience plus que les hommes
je pense que les hommes dans ce je pense
que les hommes ont plutôt cette volonté
de challenge et c'est un peu un jeu pour
eux de négocier donc et puis c'est très
masculin l'argent donc c'est très ancrée
dans l'inconscient collectif qu'un homme
qui parle argent c'est assumer c'est un
leader c'est quelqu'un qui a de nous une
famille à nourrir alors qu'une femme qui
parle argent elle doit être très elle
doit le faire de manière très délicate
parce que très rapidement elle va tomber
dans l'écueil d'être quelqu'un de vénal
qui n'est pas intéressé par le poste
mais par l'argent qu'il procure et que
c'était donc une forme d'autocensure
évidemment il ya une forme d'auto sens
et ce sur quoi vous vous battez vous
faites moi la principale mon analogie
préféré c'est dire aux femmes si vous
aviez un appartement à vendre est-ce que
vous iriez vérifier les prix du marché
avant de mettre en vente on est d'accord
mais pourquoi vous ne le faites pas pour
vos qualifications quand il s'agit d'une
marché du travail elles ne le font pas
mais je vais vous dire pourquoi c'est
pas ce n'est pas parce qu'elles ne
veulent pas c'est parce qu'elles ne
savent pas où chercher elles ne savent
pas à qui demander et elles ne savent
pas quoi chercher et c'est là dessus que
moi je les accompagne parce que à
l'école c'est formidable ce qu'on
apprend on devient de formidables
technicienne on apprend des métiers mais
on n'apprend pas à gagner sa vie on
n'apprend pas des jeux et les enjeux de
pouvoir en entreprise et ça c'est
primordial notamment pour que les femmes
accèdent à des postes à responsabilités
parce que les postes à responsabilités
moi je le vois j'accompagne énormément
deux femmes dans la finance et pour
devenir des associés dans des grands
cabinets des grandes banques financent
avec des grandes institutions
financières c'est un boys club dans
qu'elles doivent montrer patte blanche
et démontrer qu'elles peuvent faire
partie des leurs donc il ya tout un
cérémonial est un processus et donc si
on n'a pas de sponsor si on n'a pas de
personnes qui nous dit quoi faire
comment faire à qui parler c'est très
compliqué d'accéder à ce niveau de poste
moyer ce chiffre il a peut-être un peu
évolué mais 2,6 pour cent des fonds
venant de fonds d'investissement
attribués à des femmes faire que si on
est une femme la valérie hoffenberg ans
se présente pour on est on est start up
on a une belle idée on est en train de
créer son entreprise si on est une femme
on a beaucoup beaucoup moins de chance
de dettes refinancées en revanche si
déjà on a un homme à côté c'est à dire
qu'il ya un cofondateur ça va un peu
mieux moi je trouve ça complètement
dingue il sauf que moi je viens de
monter une société et donc j'ai fait ma
première levée de fonds est donc gg
lever de l'argent et je crois qu'il ya
effectivement deux choses la première
c'est que les femmes elles ont toujours
le sentiment qu'elles doivent prouver
qu'elles sont à la hauteur donc pourquoi
est-ce que lorsqu'elles sont dans une
société où lorsqu'elles vont voir un
fonds d'investissement elles vont pas
négocié de la même manière qu'un homme
parce qu'elles ont ce faible syndrome de
l'imposteur et elle doit se dire je vais
d'abord prouver que je suis bonne et
ensuite ils vont augmenter donc alors
qu'un homme ne va pas faire ça un homme
va aller il va dire je suis bon jeu mais
raide ça alors qu'ils méritent peut-être
exactement la même chose que l'autre
donc il ya il faut travailler sur l'état
d'esprit des femmes ont leur disant vous
mériter autant ce n'est pas vénal parce
qu'on reste avec cet imaginaire quand
même de la femme qui parle d'argent est
une femme intéressée et vénale donc il
faut absolument travailler sur ces
stéréotypes là et puis ensuite quand on
parle des femmes et des fonds
d'investissement marie le dire à tout à
l'heure mais première étape c'est lutter
contre ce boys band et donc faire en
sorte qu'il y ait effectivement plus de
femmes aussi dans les fonds
d'investissement que lorsqu'il y a des
banques eba il faudrait que peut-être
face à des dossiers il faut qu'il y ait
ce dossier soit jugé par un homme et
pour une femme et pour une raison toute
bête c'est que tout simplement certaines
femmes
avons créé des choses qui s'adresse aux
femmes et qu'elles ne vont pas avoir
obligatoirement avec un homme en face la
même compréhension de l'enjeu et
deuxièmement c'est vrai que nous avons
aussi une façon de nous exprimer une
façon de parler de présenter les
objectifs qui peut être un peu
différente et je pense qu'il serait un
des éléments seraient déjà que quand on
présente dans un fonds d'investissement
il faut que le panel de jury soit à
parité hommes femmes il ya évidemment
des réseaux il ya le réseau femmes
business angels auquel je pensais un
fonds d'investissement qui s'appelle les
ja capital qui est spécialisée dans
l'accompagnement des des start up des
jeunes entreprises
fondées par des femmes ou en mixité
femmes hommes vous l'avez vécu vous
aussi dans une levée de fond ça a été
très difficile de convaincre c'est ça
alors oui j'ai fait trois levées de
fonds donc oui oui ça a été très
difficile parce que moi c'est réseau
d'affaires pour les femmes
entrepreneures plus bouge ton groupe
pour faciliter les carrières des femmes
donc c'est à destination d'autres femmes
donc femme à destination d'autres femmes
en plus dans les territoires parce qu'on
est très implanté dans toutes les villes
de france et moi un pari je vous assure
que ça a été compliqué parce que
forcément je me retrouvais parfois face
à 20 ou 30 business angels ou par par
exemple des fonds et comme tu comme tu
disais il ya déjà un sentiment de
discrédit qui est assez fort mais qui
est inconscient parce que en fait il
s'agit pas de culpabiliser les hommes en
disant voilà en fait c'est comme ça il
ya un éveil qui est là depuis quelques
années sur ce sujet là mais les billets
sont encore très fort donc ce regard
inconscient sur nous en tant que femme
entrepreneur il est compliqué et nous
mêmes nous avons dévié donc il faut
vraiment travailler nous les femmes à
enlever c'est bien là et comme tu disais
ça passe par les formations la
sensibilisation et les hommes sinon
qu'il ya tout un travail et par rapport
à ce que vous disiez tout à l'heure il
ya 90 % des faux qui vont xda des
entreprises exclusivement porté par des
hommes donc 100% masculine 88 % des
fonds en france ce qui est gigantesque
après à 16% pour les équipes mixtes ya
une loi qui est qui n'a pas été
mentionné et qui pourtant est vraiment
importante c'est la loire x1 qui a été
voté le jour de noël donc c'est un beau
cadeau l'année dernier r loire x1 qui
permet d'avoir 30 % de femmes des quotas
30 % de femmes dans les instances
dirigeantes donc là on parle vraiment
des comex et pas des conseils
d'administration qui ont été évoqués
tout à l'heure 30% de femmes en 2027 40%
en 2040 est en fait celle des pénalités
ce n'est pour les entreprises qui ne
après deux ans avec deux ans deux ans
après
la mise en place des quotas donc
2030 et 2000 un peu de temps il ya un
peu de temps mais effectivement et des
pénalités financières qui sont prévues
et ce dont on ne se rend pas compte
aujourd'hui on n'a pas encore pris toute
la mesure de cette loi rixin on ne se
rend pas compte à quel point ça va
transformer les organisations parce que
pour avoir 30% de femmes c'est long il
faut créer les viviers ça se fait pas en
un coup de baguette magique il faut
former il faut transformer il faut
transformer le management notamment la
façon de recruter tu en as parlé tout à
l'heure la façon de communiquer et on se
rend pas compte à quel point ça va
transformer les organisations et qu'il
faut s'y mettre dès maintenant je
voudrais faire un zoom maintenant sur le
ces inégalités dans les milieux ruraux
avec vous bruno belin je rappelle que
vous faisiez partie des rapporteurs des
travaux menés au sénat sur sur ce thème
peut-être quelques chiffres combien de
femmes vivant en milieu rural et de
quelle inégalités supplémentaires
souffre-t-elle vous avez parlé de la
mobilité tout à l'heure il y en
ad'autres j'imagine
11000 inaugural donc évidemment
considérable et ça nous est pris en
compte dans nos de toutes les réflexions
de des politiques publiques alors
mobilité bien évidemment carrière
professionnelle c'est évident inégalités
sur la santé aussi les femmes passent
après tout ils ont plus de difficultés à
trouver des créneaux de rendez vous
rejoins la question de la mobilité ou
c'est qu'en france il ya treize
départements mis à rude des coûts donc
voilà je sens de difficultés
insupportables et n'essaie sur quasiment
tous les thèmes où on a vu que les
indices étaient encore plus défavorable
effectivement aux femmes en milieu rural
et puis ils n'étaient pas les échanges
très intéressants avant cette
intervention et notamment sur les
obligations qui pourrait y avoir
mais je pense qu'elle devrait être
immédiate je prends des exemples simples
un cabinet ministériel aujourd'hui on va
pénaliser éventuellement un ministère
s'il
n'est pas justement dans ces politiques
de paris vous imaginez ça veut dire qu'à
un ministre à payer une amende avec de
l'argent public allait donc encaissé
lui-même sa demande à mon avis ça ne
mobilise pas trop les ministres il
faudrait donc une obligation
voilà dès demain quand il meilleur deux
nouveaux ministres à composer des
cabinets qui soit paritaire comme je lé
fais moi quand je présidais département
de la vienne et puis puisqu'on parle des
collectivités locales c'est très sain
possible c'est qu'elles ont l'obligation
des départements les régions les grandes
métropoles de présenter un rapport sur
l'égalité hommes-femmes et bien pourquoi
pas envisager la publication des 20 plus
hauts salaires des 50 plus gros salaires
je crois que ça ça participerait au
débat et à l'émulation des salaires
alors justement vous parliez finalement
de l'état ou du ou des services publics
des pouvoirs publics donne-t-il exemple
on va rentrer un peu dans le temps on
voit que c'est pas forcément vrai alors
même si cette semaine il ya eu un un
bastion historiquement masculin qui est
tombé enfin la présidence de l'assemblée
nationale belle étape pour yaël boon
privé on écoute
un grand moment de la vie démocratique
dans notre pays
c'est l'aboutissement d'un long chemin
de l'égalité entre les hommes et les
femmes sur le plan institutionnel il ya
encore beaucoup à faire mais là nous
venons de franchir une très belle étape
laetitia on va parler d' emmanuel macron
si vous le voulez bien est ce que le
président de la république a tenu parole
écoutez les engagements sont là pourquoi
parce que c'est la deuxième fois que
manuel macron nous dit que l'égalité
femmes hommes puisqu'ils utilisent cet
ordre là sera la grande cause de son
quinquennat donc on va ré écouter
emmanuel macron il présentait son
programme on était en pleine campagne
c'était le 17 mars la grande cause de
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
de la lutte contre les violences à
l'égalité salariale
et tant et tant d'autres combats nous
l'avons emmené nos associations se sont
mobilisées
mais nous devrons faire plus nous
devrons faire plus c'est pourquoi à
nouveau l'égalité femmes-hommes sera la
grande cause de quinquennat qui s'ouvre
alors ce qui est intéressant je vous
proposais de faire un tout petit retour
en arrière dans le magazine vanity fair
en 2017 emmanuel macron a dit je suis un
converti tardif au féminisme mais comme
tous les convertis je suis résolu alors
en cinq ans il a donné quelques gages
c'est vrai le grenelle sur les violences
faites aux femmes la création d'un
énième conseil consultatif pour l
égalité femmes hommes qui étaient
chargés c'était un été 2010 9,1 de
remettre un rapport il ya une parité
quand même dans la nomination des
ministres et puis des nominations
remarquez comme celle par exemple de
laurence des cars à la tête du louvre
mais emmanuel macron s'il en fait encore
une fois cela cause de son quinquennat
ça veut dire que tous les objectifs ne
sont pas atteints d'ailleurs il l'avait
dit un pendant la campagne sis dans une
interview face aux françaises ils
avaient dit les les progrès sociaux sont
longs à obtenir donc oui 5 ans n'ont pas
été suffisants on continue donc il ya
une forme de volontarisme politique on
l'entend et
1 mm macro assez paradoxal aussi écouter
c'est un paradoxe à lui tout seul
pourquoi parceque il brandit cette cause
un d'égalité femmes hommes mais il ne
s'entoure lui que d'hommes pour
gouverner la france son noyau dur est
exclusivement masculin bien sûr à
l'exception de sa femme qui joue un
grand rôle dans la présidence donc
brigitte macron mais sinon il y à
stéphane séjourné thierry solère richard
ferrand christophe castaner ismaël et
manière à ses débuts pour ne citer
qu'eux et c'est vrai qu'on l'a vu thomas
en temps de crise c'est cette bulle qui
dirige la france a rappelé vous la photo
qui avait crispé emmanuel macron pendant
la campagne ces quatre hommes qui
étaient censés être la vitrine de
renaissance d'ensemble la nouvelle
majorité présidentielle quatre hommes
blancs edouard philippe stanislas
guérini françois bayrou et richard
ferrand tous avec une mine mortuaires
alors le canard enchaîné ensuite avait
fait savoir et donc emmanuel macron
certainement directement au canard
enchaîné ou ses conseillers qu'il avait
été très énervé un de voir cette photo
que pour lui ça ressemblait plus à un
enterrement et que c'était une faute ce
sont les mots d' emmanuel macron de m
aucune femme sur la photo d'accord très
bien ça c'est du storytelling ça
s'appelle de la communication politique
car oui et à emmanuel macron s'est
énervé mais autour de lui je persiste et
je signe il n'ya que des hommes donc on
oublie aussi alexis colère son double
alexis colère très très un président à
l'elysée un très influent dans la
positon emmanuel macron je pose la
question ce soir pourquoi emmanuel
macron ne gouverne pas avec des femmes
conseillé par des femmes pourquoi pas
valérie hoffenberg vous voyez le verre à
moitié plein ou à moitié vide
j'ai toujours je suis une optimiste de
nature donc je le vois toujours
le verre à moitié à moitié plein en
revanche efficient il a raison et
emmanuel macron il n'a pas fini et il a
du boulot parce qu'il ya plein de choses
qui ont été faites il ya eu de très
bonnes lois qui ont été votées
maintenant il ya encore beaucoup
beaucoup de travail est vraiment j'ai
été très touché par le témoignage de
monsieur le sénateur c'est vrai que ans
particulièrement par exemple dans les
campagnes sur les femmes dans l'est dans
les territoires il ya énormément de
problèmes il est dans le monde problème
surtout ce qui est la santé et quand on
parle salaires il faut savoir que ce
salary les dents et percussions tout au
long de la vie et sur les retraites je
crois que là aussi on va parler retraite
chez moi j'attire l'attention assure
aussi la retraite des femmes parce que
la leur elles sont très fortes walker
absolument je suis bonne que prévu si
les retraités pauvres c'est 80% de
femmes c'est à dire qu'en fait on à la
retraite des femmes c'est un élément qui
est très important qui j'espère sera
pris en compte par le gouvernement quand
on va le faire donc des écarts d
beaucoup de choses sur les violences
faites aux femmes certes il ya eu du
volontarisme mais les résultats ne sont
pas au rendez vous donc là encore c'est
des sujets sur lesquels il va falloir
vraiment travailler mais encore une fois
je pense que l'horaire le président doit
donner l'impulsion il faut quand même
saluer la nomination d'une première
ministre d'une président de l'assemblée
je crois même qu est quand même la
présidente du groupe là raymond roberge
et donc il y a effectivement donc des
gestes qui sont importants et qui
permettent justement de briser ce tabou
d'avoir aux gaffes des femmes et du
pouvoir maintenant maintenant sur le
terrain il ya encore beaucoup de choses
à faire au delà de la question du bilan
des macros il ya quand même ce constat
sur la fonction publique regardez ces
chiffres on parle de l'encadrement
supérieur et des dirigeants dans la
fonction publique seulement un tiers de
ses emplois d'encadrement sont occupés
par des femmes c'est le rapport de la
délégation aux droits des femmes du
sénat sur la parité qui vient d'être
publié et si on regarde les ministères
s'intéressant aussi au ministère des
affaires sociales on va trouver 43 % de
femmes et au ministère de l'économie et
des finances on va trouver 27%
deux femmes mariées loi finalement on
est dans ce que vous décriviez tout à
l'heure là quand on voit ce comparatif
affaires sociales pour les femmes
économie finance a maintenant il faut
qu'il faut qu'il y ait des garçons c'est
ça rejoint même les chiffres sur les les
ceux qui choisissent ou non aux
mathématiques en terminale on a encore
beaucoup moins de jeunes filles qui
choisissent les mathématiques en
terminale code garçons oui et souvent on
dit oui mais regarde la justice
l'éducation il ya là il ya plein de
femmes qu'on va tout en haut c'est
pareil on retombe autour de 20 à 25% de
femmes seulement et encore une fois
c'est intéressant de renverser à chaque
fois les chiffres
bruno belin cesser ces chiffres ils
sortent d'une d'un rapport donc de la
délégation aux droits des femmes du
sénat sur la parité dans la haute
fonction publique pourquoi l'état ne
donne pas l'exemple moi c'est aussi une
des choses qui me choquent qui m'a
choqué en préparant cette émission
c'est pour ça qu'il faut parce
qu'effectivement on dort une analyse sur
ce qu'on appelle la loi sauvanet un
regard quelques années après et ados
gays on voit bien que dans l'efficience
des résultats et des politiques et
maillard a toujours un écart est donc
vraiment je vais je vais continuer mais
aussi à rabâcher il faut que nous dans
nos responsabilités eh bien on continue
à affirmer que les recrutements doivent
ou deux mais c'est tout à l'heure je
vous parlais
des salaires c'est pas anodin parce que
bien dans les rapports des collectivités
où tout ce qui est plus en public on
cachera derrière d indice majoré
brouille tout ce qu'on veut c'est pas
forcément parlant il faut qu'il y ait
vraiment une publication des salaires y
compris dans les cabinets ministériels
dans la haute fonction publique
je crois qu'il faut pas qu'on ait
c'était le début du débat de votre
émission on a peut-être encore un tabou
sur la
foi aussi évolué c'est suggérer c'est ce
qui fera la force de tout et de tous
mais il ya des pénalités là aussi à des
sanctions avec les ministères préfèrent
payer des des sanctions que de nommer
des femmes à des postes
d'encadrement
tout le monde trouve risible que les
ministères et des sanctions c'est à dire
que avec de l'argent au public
l'état verse à l'état et et puis c'est
sans conséquence
il faut obliger un ministère à avoir un
cabinet paritaire il faut comme on l'a
fait tout simplement d'entrer conseil
département dans les communes de plus de
militants nous on propose même de dans
les communes rurales eu des 500
habitants qui avaient les exécutifs sur
la parité appelés conseillers municipaux
soient paritaire voilà ça doit devenir
quelque chose de tout à fait simple
fluide évident et il faut arracher pour
qu'il ya encore des progrès à faire
parce qu'on voit bien que sur le terrain
il ya des souffrances comprenez exemple
des disparités en milieu rural donc il
ya tellement à faire qu'il faut
mobiliser et alors on sait bien que
voilà j'entendais tout à l'heure une
intervenante dire dans l'éducation il ya
peut être plus de femmes dans le monde
de la science du travail on avait
effectivement à plus de femmes mais il
faut qu' effectivement ce travail sur
les salaires et les migrations les
carrières des possibilités tenir compte
et bien évidemment des maternités dans
le monde agricole une disparité total
dans la retraite les mondes aussi des
conjoints collaborateurs des artisans
des commerçants donc il ya un énorme
travail à faire en poker très bien que
non merci je joue parce que les
îles on n'est pas très bonne donc je
vous interromps pour redonner la parole
à une salle el assidi je sais peut-être
pas votre champ de d'action la fonction
publique je sais pas si vous avez des
oui c'est mon champ d'action et c'est
vrai on peut négocier sans son
traitement à la fonction publique
contrairement à ce que l'on croit et à
ce qui est matraqué mais je vous laisse
poser votre question non mais c'est ça
je voulais vous demander s'il y avait
beaucoup de deux femmes qui venaient
vous voir qui était dans la fonction
publique et qu'ils étaient confrontés
voilà c'est à ces disparités qui sont
aux aussi voire plus choquant parce que
c'est le cdta alors oui absolument il ya
des femmes qui exercent dans la fonction
publique et qui viennent me voir la
majorité vient de moi me voir parce
qu'elles sont en profonde souffrance on
s'aperçoit aujourd'hui que le socle de
notre société c'est quand même
l'éducation et la santé cds secteur
d'activité qui sont très largement
menés par des femmes essaient des
secteurs d'activité où les rémunérations
sont quand même largement en dessous de
la juste contribution tiapoum là à notre
société à notre société et à ce secteur
d'activité donc déjà je pense qu'au delà
des déclarations d'intention si
l'égalité femmes hommes est réellement
sérieusement une vraie cause du
quinquennat alors il faut mettre en
oeuvre et il faut injecter des fonds
pour revaloriser les salaires des
infirmières des enseignantes et de tout
secteur d'activité là pour en revenir à
votre question et sur le fait de savoir
si des les fonctionnaires de
l'administration publique peuvent
négocier leur salaire alors oui
évidemment ils ne vont pas négocier leur
salaire fixe puisque c'est une question
de voilà le traitement est en fonction
de l'échelle qui est déterminé par un
concours en revanche à une pléthore de
primes que les femmes n'ont pas du tout
conscience et je vais vous donner un
exemple que j'ai eu avec l'une de mes
nez mais le mes élèves ou dernier mot
tout dernier au quai d'orsay qui a
travaillé énormément qui n'a pas eu
accès à une prime parce qu'elle n'en
avait pas connaissance alors que son
successeur et son prédécesseur avait une
crime et la prime évidemment elle est
bien élevé le niveau de rémunération
merci beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir
participé à ce débat c'était passionnant
merci également aux sénateurs bruno
belin d'être intervenu et désolé pour
ces petites coupures de
deux liaisons jeu